Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
What if we tried to build a generative adversarial
network for 3D data?
This means that this network would work not
on the usual 2 dimensional images, but instead,
on 3 dimensional shapes.
So, the generator network generates a bunch
of different 3 dimensional shapes, and the
basic question for the discriminator network
would be - are these 3D shapes real or synthetic?
The main use case of this technique can be,
and now watch closely, taking a photograph
from a piece of furniture, and automatically
getting a digital 3D model of it.
Now it is clear for both of us that this is
still a coarse, low resolution model, but
it is incredible to see how a machine can
get a rudimentary understanding of 3D geometry
in the presence of occlusions, lighting, and
different camera angles.
That's a stunning milestone indeed!
It also supports interpolation between two
shapes, which means that we consider the presumably
empty space between the shapes as a continuum,
and imagine new shapes that are closer to
either one or the other.
We can do this kind of interpolation, for
instance between two chair models.
But the exciting thing is that no one said
it has to be two objects of the same class.
So we can go even crazier, and interpolate
between a car and a boat.
Since the technique works on a low-dimensional
representation of these shapes, we can also
perform these crazy algebraic operations between
them that follow some sort of intuition.
We can add two chairs together or subtract
different kinds of tables from each other.
Absolute madness.
And one of the most remarkable things about
the paper is that the learning took place
on a very limited amount of data, not more
than 25 training examples per class.
One class we can imagine as one object type,
such as, chairs, tables or cars.
The authors made the the source code and a
pretrained network available on their website,
the link is in the video description, make
sure to have a look!
I am so happy to see breakthroughs like this
in machine learning research.
One after another in quick succession.
This work is surely going to spark a lot of
followup papers, and we'll soon find ourselves
getting extremely high quality 3D models from
photographs.
Also, imagine combining this with a 3D printer!
You take a photograph of something, run this
algorithm on it, and then print a copy of
that furniture or appliance for yourself.
We are living amazing times indeed!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!